[Música]
eeuu se encuentra en un punto de
inflexión una época de peligro real pero
de posibilidades extraordinarias podemos
elegir el camino de estar más enojados
menos esperanzados más disminuidos un
camino de sombra y sospechas o podemos
elegir un camino diferente y juntos
aprovechar esta oportunidad para sanar
renacer we must be light president
debemos elegir a un presidente que nos
ofrezca algo diferente algo mejor en
judy en work
y que haga el trabajo importante un
presidente que nos una a todos negros
blancos latinos asiáticos indígenas para
conseguir el futuro que queremos
colectivamente
nunca esperé que mi sucesor a adoptar a
mi visión no continuará con mis
políticas
si esperaba por el bien de mi país
mostrará algo de interés en tomarse en
su trabajo
[Música]
by the numbers tenemos que votar por joe
biden en cifras que no puedan ser
ignoradas porque ahora mismo personas
que saben que no pueden ganar de manera
justa en las urnas están haciendo todo
lo posible para evitar que votemos
[Música]
the nation
juntos debemos construir una nación que
sea más equitativa más compasiva y sé
que yo vaivén comenzará esa lucha desde
el primer día iovine wall big in that
faith and the world
[Música]
en un momento en el que millones de
personas en eeuu están buscando
soluciones sistémicas y también al
sistema de salud
en el espíritu del pueblo y desde el
amor a todas las personas quiero nominar
al senador bernie sanders de vermont
para ser presidente de los eeuu de
américa
[Música]
si usamos la única economía industrial
que tiene una tasa de desempleo
triplicado en tiempos así la oficina web
debería ser un centro de comando está
bien lugar es un centro de tormentas
solamente y caos
[Música]
si somos fuertes juntos vamos a sanar
juntos vamos a volver a tomar la promesa
de nuestro país liderados por nuestro
presidente joe biden y la vicepresidenta
kamala harris
[Música]
donald trump heredó una economía
creciente y un miembro más pacífico y
como todo lo demás que heredó lo llevó a
la banca cuando este presidente va al
exterior no es una misión de buena
voluntad es una burla rompe con nuestros
aliados escribe cartas de amor a
dictadores eeuu no merece un presidente
del cual la gente de este riesgo
nuestra fortaleza es el gobierno ese es
nuestro sistema inmune y ahora mismo
tenemos un gobierno que no puede luchar
contra el virus
[Música]